Rachel Hansen on the front desk
hey hey getting complaints about a woman
crying hysterically yeah you know what I
hear her too and it sounds like she's
having such a hard time I think it's
coming from the floor above me you're on
the top floor oh I'll try to keep it
down I love you I love you I'm not even
embarrassed to say I just oh I love you
I'm not embarrassed well for you I love
you
it's like why don't we say that every
day why can't we say it more often
I just love you I just want to go the
rooftops and scream I love my best
friend Evan we should go up oh my
you're sitting over there for the past
two hours not being able to take my eyes
off of you is a fact I find you very
attractive do you find me attractive
yes I do you do
she does yes she does I don't let me do
because I'm a season 1 holder of us yes
have you seen it
have you seen season 1 no exactly so you
might have the knowledge is falling to
you do not listen men do not dance they
work they drink they have bad backs they
do not dance hold still hold tight
whatever you do do not dance
why don't you get off your board and get
on get out to view my dreams and into my
car are you are you're looking for your
pot of gold why does everything I do
sound like a leprechaun you tell me oh
you speak second I like the coolest man
on earth
the name is bull there you go oh yeah
the name is James Bond just and the
tears alright simple I'll pick the girl
then you got six weeks to turn you into
the prom queen okay okay regain okay
everybody has a big Jimmy now can we
just you got it so you would share your
bed and your fortune with a beautiful
fool that is the way it has always been
with men of power it is tradition it is
also tradition that times must and
always do change my friends